hi everyone um it's uh Freddy sento here
I'm a future Trader and here we have um
today we have a Jasper which is the
founder and also a future Strader for
for gets boot uh hi Jasper how you
doing great hi
Freddy Hi man hi thank you so much for
for you know taking uh some some of your
busy time uh to be you know to be here
and and try to explain a Futures Trader
how to actually trade the features
Market with with gets Bo I know I know
um you know we've been couple of
interviews with John in Spanish um so
probably what we what I try to do we're
going to do this one in English for the
English speaking community in the
channel and then I'm gonna do um kind of
the translation into Spanish so we can
show it in in laan um yeah that sounds
great to me um I know that like you know
uh I've done quite a bit of rambling on
Discord when people have asked questions
you know about like the practical way of
of reading gex spot um so you know I
think this is great to have an actual
compiled video form um of everything
that I've sort of been rambling about
yeah that's that's that's amazing I mean
to be honest um as I told you before I
trade basically the es Futures you know
Futures on this on
SPX but I also take positions in in the
NQ in the nasda right but I don't look
into into your um into your screen that
you guys develop because you know it for
me is quite difficult to to to
understand so that's hopefully you're
here and you can you can let us know you
can teach us how to use it better um but
yeah so a little bit about me first um
so I had started like learning about the
options Market uh from this indicator
called nope was created someone by
someone called Lily and so the idea
behind that tool was to track net Delta
inventory uh from market makers and to
determine you know where it might be
most likely for hedging flows to come in
and cause reversions right so the idea
was okay we're measuring something and
it's likely that due to some inventory
you know we could look for a scalp or a
bounce off some level okay and then from
there I started reading about spot gamma
um I I think this is pretty common for a
lot of people I know you Freddy also
started learning about Gamma through
spot gamma um and I would take their so
they have like pre-market levels right
so they would measure gamma by open
interest and you know generally you just
look for these scalps off these levels
um yeah but for me I was like okay well
sure these are like static levels that
might be working great great but you
know the market changes quite a bit on
an intraday basis um so my my thinking
with with gex spot was okay well you
know maybe I'll start plotting gex by
volume and see how that inventory shifts
uh in real time right so that was sort
of this very very start and like you
know gex spot started as very very
simple you know I would make a plot I
would like save an image and I check the
image and um it's grown into this whole
thing
um and yeah so you know we've also done
a lot of work to
filter um or to really look at our
transactions such that you know we're
not just looking at some naive uh
volume thing sorry I have to set a
little bit differently right now that's
fine um I think it's quite amaz I mean
like basically when I start to to see gu
is I I was using classic at the time
where you guys were only doing classic
and you know it work well for me for me
reverting trades so basically all I have
to do was the price to go down to the
maximum negative Gamma or to go at the
maximum positive gamma and trying to
find a mean reverting trade but the
thing is that was quite
simplistic I mean compared to have right
now because your tools I mean have right
now well it's it's very limited right so
like you have effectively kind of three
pivot you have like a neutral right um
you have like upside Max upside Max
downside etc etc um but there's you
know spending enough time especially
with you know SPX like it it forms this
this it always forms this sort of
distribution where like you see this
curve to the upside this curve to the
downside and like there's just no
granularity and you can't really tell
when like there's actual changing in in
inventory like actual shifts in
positions you know that's that was sort
of the impetus behind something like
state where now you can see kind of the
disperate you know Longs or shorts that
come in
um I think we were like coming up into
major positive and then we came back
down and there was like these shorts
here
um
yeah is is um can we go back to to the
preview uh the latest on oh night minut
yeah so basically basically to um from
people in in I'm sure you the guys in
your community they know about this but
um the the the the green bars that's
basically positive gamma right so that's
that's actually a magnet for the price
to go up is it is it so okay this is
this is something that uh no this is
very common uh discussion
so the way we started initially was you
know even after we had classified um our
transactions let me actually back up a
little bit um so we have you know we're
tracking these transactions you know
these contracts this is just looking at
the zero day or current day expiration
and then we're saying okay you know
these contracts were bought and so they
have positive volume or these contracts
were sold so they have negative volume
um but you know at the time of creating
our gex profile like the common I guess
literature you could say you know
especially from like spot gamma was
there's the assumption that calls have
positive gamma and puts have negative
gamma um but that's really due to you
know there's that assumption where every
call by customers are sold and every put
is bought
therefore the market maker exposure is
flipped so market makers are long those
calls short the puts and then such that
they're long Gamma or positive Gamma or
short gamma but in reality so so this is
just saying there's a great deal of call
gamma okay uh and the red bars are where
there's put gamma and it's actually
ignoring the direction uh it wasn't
until we developed options profile to
then display the actual okay this is
true this is what we call Long gamma but
this is basically customers being long
contracts here there're being short
contracts uh in the purple bars and then
there long contracts
here guess that that's interesting that
you mention that because in the channel
I also see I mean in the state Channel I
see people get confused and they ask you
many times is it is it like um is it the
client which is long or is it the market
maker which is long you know who who is
long who
is so I so basically our view is
customer view so um whether that's like
you know some institution or retail
probably not retail actually not an NX
uh but generally we're looking at
customer positions and you know the
reason for that is I know that like
traditionally people typically talk
about you know market makers and talking
about the hedging activities and like
there there is like a systemic effect
from that but at least what we found is
you know what's more practically
effective is just knowing what the
customers are doing because it's really
the customers that are driving the
primary flows right so they're they're
hedging so we can think of as sort of a
chain right so like customer is trying
to put some position on with with
respect to the index and then they put
on they come to the options Market to
put on their
Hedges and then subsequently market
makers who are accepting those trades
you know then they're hedging their
flipped version of that trade um you
know and there's all these second order
effects from that but I think it's more
important to think of okay well the
customer came in and they're hedging
long gamma here and what does that mean
or how does that fect spot price or they
long gamma here you know how does that
affect spot price as we come into you
know these levels
okay and to be more concrete you know
like and I've said this in like the chat
went not but I do want to say here like
you know it's very very
um I think it's less complicated than it
needs to be yeah so it's literally just
people are if they're long gamma
um their long volatility in in this area
which just means that like they're
expecting a move away from this level
right so if you think about being long a
straddle right yes what you're really
asking for is spot to move away from
wherever that strike is and that's all
that this is this is just you know I
know that there's a distinction between
whether you're looking for reversions
off a long call Long call gamma or long
put gamma um um but all that matters is
that someone is long volatility in this
point and so we're looking for
reversions off long gamma
um I don't have this loaded actually
I'll load this while we're talking that
makes
sense yeah that's like the core of um
how I think about long short camma and
then there's there's other aspects of
like call put gamma you know a little
bit more
um I think they would be secondary in
terms of thinking about shorts in
control or or Longs in control
um but you know so like I think this is
around 12
today where we are auctioning up to I
think it was 701 yeah
mq and then right here is this position
that gets put on that's should
that um and it's just it's just a cap
you know it's a ceiling and we're unable
to push through and then we smallart
price rejects off of it and we come back
to the other pivot here I'm not sure if
if I'm doing it right but the the way I
I think you put it in the chat and
please correct me if I'm wrong but if if
the spot price is above of of the gamma
levels in that let's say like where you
are now we Ed this gamma levels as a
support so so as you said before those
guys in the options markets they want
the price to go as far away as possible
and once like now the spot Market I mean
the spot price is below that gamma level
that's actually kind of resistance so
those guys so so so that's the ne effect
is a is a barrier is a resistance and we
would expect the price to come down is
that all right is is a good way to
analyze that or not yeah I I think that
I think it's really
important to think in terms of like just
pivots and maybe this is a little too
esoteric but to not like I try not to
think about Direction very much if that
makes sense so like okay you know
[Music]
um there there's a comment saying like
in Futures right like don't okay I don't
say that but like don't diddle in the
middle right where like don't get stuck
in in the middle of the range right
you're looking at like the most extreme
ends or pivots right entries where you
can kind of
Define um where your your trade is wrong
and so like it's you know partly it's
like yes if we're underneath it it's
resistance if we're above it it's it's
support um but it's just you know this
is an entry for looking for spot price
to go away from from this level um you
know I I I brought this up before to
someone a while this was a long time ago
where like we had the thought of
flipping the chart you know sideways so
that you're not trading up or down
you're just trading left to right in
order to remove like the directional
bias because I know that people have a
hard time shorting because people are
much more used to going long um but I
think I it's probably too esoteric to
flip the chart um but like trying to
think in terms of you know not about
like now this is not totally true
because if you look in a long-term basis
there is there's drift right like at
least the American Market always goes up
so like you should have a long bias so
like it's not true that there isn't a
difference between being long or short
um but I think on an intraday basis like
it can can help thinking about that and
like that's all that this is right this
is just about finding those points where
or those areas where you can um you can
look to enter or exit right yeah because
you know this is like kind of the more
you do it the more you you wash it the
more you kind of get some I don't know
some knowledge or or some something into
your eyes you kind of recognize what's
happening and and for instance when the
price went up to um you know to to the
top no no worries M it start to come
down and then on the left hand side you
got the purple bars and and that purple
bars are like kind of negative gamma
right
so yeah funny at least at least on NQ I
don't even I realize I don't even look
at the I just I just straight up ignore
them I that's what I'm gonna ask you
because every day you see those bars
every day I mean and you see many of
them so so I didn't know how to really
understand those purple bars because I
thought like well this is this is people
with negative Gamma or what it is or
should I ignore that what do you
Reon
so
um I think for a lot of future Traders I
think could
really an
easy analogy to understand because I'm
sure a lot of people are familiar with
like volume profile yeah and so in
volume profile methodology you're you
typically thinking people are thinking
about
um let me actually draw this so people
are thinking of
like uh this distri bution
right right and this is like your volume
profile and then you have your not V but
like you have your upper ends and lower
ends right yeah and I think you're not
something happen because I'm not seeing
what you're showing oh it's not oh got
you okay well that's fine so people are
thinking about you know a volume profile
right sort of like this and you know
there's the high volume node which is an
hvn and the thinking is that
historically you know this is where the
most volume
transacted and so the idea is that this
is where the highest liquidity is
because this is where people are most
willing to transact and you know because
the auction is about matching buyers and
sellers right it's not really about
speculating it's about facilitating
transactions and so like if you're in a
high volume area it's very likely for
spot price to get stuck so to speak just
because it's sort of found its fair
value kind of and there's no reason for
it to to move you know now in Futures
you all we care about is like spot price
moving because that's all that we can
trade right like we're not trading
options we're not making plays off of
volatility um so we tend to avoid high
volume nodes and the converse of that is
low volume nodes right where the
thinking is that people are unwilling to
transact here because there weren't
transactions historically and thus you
know if you're going to join some Trend
or if you're looking for some reversion
trade you know you're trying to enter in
some low volume node or low volume area
now this is quite literally that so long
gamma
is is basically the equivalent of a low
volume node um and short gamma is the
quotequote equivalent of high volume
areas and that's what I mean by like I
literally only look at long gamma in the
sense of you know if you're trading
Futures typically you you you want to
avoid high volume uh nodes in the volume
profile just because it's very hard to
Define like your your thesis right it's
really hard to Define where you should
place or stop um because you know like
distribution get pretty wide right so
you try to stick to these these areas
now okay that actually brings me to
another point right so like I started
with um orderflow or I start with like
footprint there's a there there's a
lecture by branagan Barrett there's an
Axia Futures lecture which is really
great um but no so so my my background
was like okay I would look at footprint
I would look at orderflow I look for
absorption and initiation right and then
that's how I determine entries and then
the combination of that or I would
combine that with volume profile right
so in volume profile I'd be like okay
well this is low volume area I want to
Traverse the distribution to go to the
other end right um what I found was that
like at least for me footprint was just
very
noisy um you know on like a tape reading
level it's very difficult it takes a lot
of stream time to really understand what
the hell is going on yeah and if you try
to quantify it it's very prone to
overfitting um what I mean by
overfitting is like okay maybe we see
absorption at some level but what is the
significance of that right like okay
yeah someone's loading a large amount of
volume and so that implies that maybe
that's the weekly low but you don't
really have any concrete way of
measuring okay what an actual large
amount of volume is right yeah second
it's also very localized right like you
can only see orderflow at wherever spot
price currently is and so you're you're
looking at it and like you don't really
I mean that's where volume profile comes
in right where you have a map bird's eye
view and you look for the pivots um so
that kind
of at least for me like that's where
gex's profile sort of combines both of
them so we have you know the way that
we're classifying transactions is not
arbitrary meaning you know we're not
like trying to um torture some
parameters so the model says The Bu um
we're also not doing something
as uh I don't I don't want to say simple
but like you know doing bid ass
classification is not really correct
either um but we're basically doing a
way that there's a fundamental uh reason
for why we classify things the way we
are so we have that
orderflow classification in the option
sense but simultaneously we get the
birds eye view of of volume profile and
it's not historical like volume profile
it's it's real time right like these are
active positions that are occurring
right now and so like we can be sure of
okay well you know we don't need to
worry about whether we're looking at a
daily or the weekly or the monthly volum
profile like this is all forward
looking and additionally they have an
expiration right so maybe someone's
getting long in the Futures Market
because they have some expectation of
like end of year flows or something but
these are zero gtes like this is this
matters here now we have a Target which
is like today and like so we can clearly
Define the limits for you know our view
into the
market yeah like
and yes no I mean that's that's the
whole point and you know the what I show
at the beginning that zero DT options
are are basically more than 50% of the
total flow on a daily basis that's
that's there are some research of good
companies that actually show that even
even the spot gamma does it and and they
have a tool where you can see you know
the total volume of of options here like
I don't know1 billion dollar and then
half of that is is uh Z DT so I think
that's what that's that's why why it's
important like for you Futures Traders
like us which day Traders basically we
want in and out very quick this this
tool is fantastic but understand the
tool understand you know basically what
you just told us before I was looking at
those purple lines before and say like
oh God Market is going down but the way
you mention is is fantastic it's it's
you know it's not simplistic but U is is
you know when you are looking so many
things and and you explaining is that
simple that that you know that saves a
lot of time and and headaches and and
many things but I I was talking to John
the other day and and try to understand
uh that um you know the volatility skew
and how to combine that with with the
chart and and probably you can give us
also as as you're a future straight that
you can give us your point of view of
you know how we can actually analyze
that yeah
so one thing I want to say is that like
you know the way that we are displaying
skew in like a traditional manner
um I
think I probably can't say that now but
the there are there are improvements
that we want to make to this view to
make it more usable from an execution
standpoint um but like so the core of
skew is is
not it's it's really simple I think so
I'm sure if you've traded Futures you're
familiar with bookmap and if you're or
maybe even like ninja Trader like um or
like the Dom right so like I know that
people like looking at stacking or
pulling of limit orders on the order
book to kind of sus out you know okay
maybe there's a willing buyer here or
there's a willing seller here right and
so like
skew or the voles are
literally it's basically um a measure of
liquidity in the same fashion that the
limit order book is when you're looking
at like the heat map on book map uh but
these are actually being traded so these
are not limit orders that are you know
because yes there's laws against
spoofing like you know there's some
degree of like you don't really know
right when you're looking at the Dom
whether someone's being real about
whether they want to put this risk on or
not like you just don't know um and
often like I've seen so many stink B on
like the the dawn where it's you know
someone at like 3500 I remember putting
some limit order in and it's like okay
well you're not serious like I know
you're not serious it's just like
messing with people right um but no the
this these these vs so to clarify um
these are the VES of the contracts the
corresponding contract so this would be
if we were looking at SPX actually
um this is just the value or the implied
follow volatility of the 5815 puts um
and volatility I think it's easiest to
think in terms of it's just the value of
that contract it's normalized in a sense
because there's a Time Dimension uh to
these options right uh but in effect you
can think of them as as the value of
them and so basically someone is trading
or people participants are trading uh
these contracts and it's implying
something about the liquidity right and
so another part of that is you can think
of volatility as the inverse of
liquidity
so I think the mo the easiest to
understand example is it's not so much
now but during like fed minute meetings
I'm sure everyone's seen where everyone
leaves the L or The Limited order book
and you know you're watching NQ and it's
just like surging around because there's
no liquidity because no one's willing to
transact because like japal might be
about to Nuke the markets right and so
like that's high volatility due to a
lack of liquidity meaning a lack of
willing uh auction participants
so and the same concept applies here so
this being higher Vols means and by
higher I mean uh this is along the
x-axis so if the V is to the right there
it's higher volatility if the dot is to
the left it's lower
volatility so higher volatility means
less people willing to transact in this
Zone and lower volatility means more
liquidity or more willingness transact
here
okay yeah it it it
may I know it's a little it's a jargon
that's a bit
much yeah but I I remember like kind of
conversation with John and he mentioned
basically is also how cheap or expensive
is an option yes and and how how are the
options guys are willing to pay for more
expensive options like the the you know
the the the expensive options
above they say like well the options
guys are not going to are not going to
beat for those prices because they're
quite expensive so you might if you are
long you know the price is not going to
go is not rocket right now because you
know options are not going to buy
options above those levels it's sort of
kind of yeah I think there's there's a
core so like you know think about
literally what an option is right you're
if you're purchasing an option you're
purchasing purchasing the right to then
transact right like if you're buying a
call the right in obligation blah blah
blah you're saying that you're you're
willing to buy um at this level but if
volatility is very high meaning the the
contract is very expensive so it's less
likely that people are willing to buy
that meaning that they're less likely
they're less willing to transact um with
that option right and so like you know
the impetus is to sell it although
that's not you know recommended because
you don't want to just sell Kinks and
the SK
indiscriminately yeah you know like like
we we in South America and joh you know
JN is from Argentina as well we like we
like simple and easy things so with
okay you know what imagine it's a roope
climber and the
GU it's going it's going very easy up to
where is the price right now you know it
can go very easy to
5875 but going up is going to be very
hard and very tough for him you know
imagine you you're climbing that rock on
the you know with um
yeah uh with everything against you so
that's that that mean price is not going
to go there so get out if you're long
you know where to get out and it's
probably at 58 90 I don't know some
level like that because you know it's
quite difficult the price to go up with
this yeah I mean my preferred analogy is
like spot price is and I've said this so
many times a joy he knows right now like
my my prefer analogy is like spot price
is a ball and if you just think about
this as okay as like you know it's a
slope right so where does the ball want
to roll you know where where does it
want to slide
um where is it easier for it to slide
right and if you think because I think
it's easier to think in terms of in
physical terms often yeah um just
because that's it comes naturally to
people right and like yes there's a lot
of there's there's quite a bit of
theoretical justification for why that
is the way it is um but you know
practically speaking if just think in
terms of like it's a ball and spot price
wants to roll on that hill and actually
so that comes to
um actually dovetails really nicely with
the idea of long or short gamma so like
long
gamma when I'm thinking about Gamma I'm
really thinking about the
vs um so when we're we're displaying
these these vs this is like the latest V
that had occurred um and if we're
looking at the gamma right so if you're
long gamma that means
you've likely lift or you have lifted
the volatility of that contract that's
how that gets classified in such a way
um if you're short gamma it's because
you've depressed the vs there um and
that's that was the effect of that
transaction and so long gamma just means
that they lifted the vs at that point
and so when we're talking about uh when
I'm talking about like reversions off of
long gamma it's the same concept of you
know the skew being less or more liquid
in some areas right so long git tells us
the history of that part of the skew
being less liquid meaning there's more
likely to have reversions off of it and
short gamma is telling us the history of
the skew being a lower volatility which
implies a higher liquidity which means
less reversion and and more momentum you
there's a lot of like flip flip-flops um
but like you know I find it helps to
just sort of write it out um and that
that helps with like thinking about it I
don't know if you can share with
us I don't know if you can share with us
you in the channel to make um a really
nice kind of
explanation do you have that so so we
can show to people um because when that
with when that uh
volatility SK is flat it's it's when you
see the market just go down or just go
up very aggressively yeah let me
try to I'm trying to download where is
this thing hold
on yes yeah so this is yeah I probably
should have had this up the whole time
uh so this is just how I think of the
voles right so it's
like U let let me just outline the cases
right so like I'm looking I'm literally
just looking at the shape of the dots
right yeah and um again so if there's
higher volatility by higher I mean the
the dot is to the right um then spot
price higher volatility is less
liquidity meaning spot price is less
likely to transact there so in this case
you know the Vols are higher underneath
spot and they're lower above spot and
therefore it's easier for spot price to
move
towards higher liquidity right so
because volatility and liquidity are are
opposites and interest enough you know
so this is a little bit different
depending on the the the asset or the
instrument right so like this is the
classic
SPX um skew okay where customer or
participants are generally long puts or
long volatility underneath spot and
they're short um calls so you can think
of like the JPM caller is like a typical
example where they are not expressing a
directional um TR but bias they're just
putting a hedge on but the nature of
that hedge is such that it is actually
inherently bullish because it's just
more difficult to push down into lifted
vs and it's easier for spot price to go
up um you know whether this is
like dog wagging tail or tail wagging
dog because traditionally you know
American socks over time always go up
right so there's a bit of that baked in
but you know that that's for another
discussion I think um now other forms of
skew can appear and and these are really
more
often they're not common I would say
that
like these are most obvious during
events and or event V and what I mean by
event V is something like you know
fomc um although that has definitely
died out a little bit if you're looking
at something like individual equities
these kinds of other forms of the skew
are definitely more apparent well event
is actually looks a little bit different
um it's really a it's a slope that's
inverse of this right so it's like a a
hill um but it's all about like spot
price being located somewhere in the
skew and where is where is liquidity and
liquidity is wherever the Vols are the
lowest right so you're just looking for
the ball to either roll down the slope
or maybe it's rolling it's stuck right
cuz like it sloped on both ways um this
actually happened yesterday at the close
right I think people were short the 15
and 20 calls in SPX we got up to that
level skew flattened out um or really
they came like this and then we just
closed in between those short
strikes and then there's there's this
example which is not as common where SK
is are straight up
flat and the effect of this is really
that like if there's spot price movement
it's a lot easier to get momentum going
so like you know this is kind of the
ideal um I mean it depends on your bias
I guess if you're tring Futures right
like you either want this or if like
you're bullish or if you you know if
you're looking to short something
um I I will say though like from a
practical
perspective um right now it's you know
there's still work to be done with
actually making these fos usable in a
way that like you don't have to be
staring at it like this because it's
very difficult to to get a same reading
yeah no but you you know what just it's
been useful to be honest I I I've been
taking positions where I go long and
then using the analogy like U you know
your ball analogy of the rock climber
this I go I go I go a a you know a
maximum gamma level at the top and on
top of that I see the skew I'm right in
the middle so the price is not going to
go any higher yeah and that's that's
where I get out basically um usually a
couple of times to be honest and it's
been quite helpful and but um I know
many people in South America they they
have seen your videos in in YouTube oh
and and and yeah yeah know they they do
they they call me and and they contact
me and they say like can just playing
this because wild they they hear about
the concept of gamma uh uh I'm telling
you here is all about support resistance
strangles moving average but when people
go and see this and they say okay
there's there's something you know
something going on behind the scen what
the hell are they looking at yeah yeah
yeah and and and obviously as I said
before the the the classic getb was was
kind of easy to to read but now you guys
with all these
tools you know you really need time and
and you know thank you for for this
explanation because you know it makes
the life of these guys of Our Lives
easier to to to trade every day with
your
tool and and um and I didn't know no no
honestly that's that's why I I said you
know I I need to talk to J and make a
video um because I really want I you
know you know my story I was an an
Institutional Trader and when I came
back to Colombia I was in London and
when I came back to Columbia a couple a
couple of years ago I saw you know
people here don't know about this they
they just still by courses for these
gurus and stuff and and you know what
you guys doing is is amazing and and
people here should know it should know
about it uh but just you know probably I
don't know if it's too much for futures
Traders but uh I think it was
yesterday I think CL you know one of
these I mean big guys they they put put
a kind of put a spread or David a spread
credit I don't know and and everyone in
the chat was like oh my God this is and
the price never went there it was some
puts or something like that and and then
you mention I quote I don't yeah I was
Wonder you say I don't care you
know all I care is is that these people
leave that part of the B surface and
make it more expensive so the spot is
not going to go there can can you just
kind of explainers a little bit
more when I say or when we say that
we're looking at a customer view um and
by customer view I mean if some you know
it's a customer that went long gamma
here or long gamma here and you know
that's like their position um it's not
quite true uh in in a
sense this like
kind of philosophical but it's sort of
not true in the sense of
[Music]
um you know really what we're looking at
is the impact of some participant you
know with his own incentives whatever
he's trying to do you know he's coming
in to the system and he puts a position
on that affects the system in such a way
in in such a way that like you know it
show shows up as being long Gamma or on
Monday you know it was long puts right
yeah they were long puts yeah but like
the whether or not the participant is
whatever his incentives are it doesn't
really matter whether he's like
speculative or hedging um what matters
is how he's affected the system because
like you know for one thing there's just
no way it's epistemologically impossible
to know whether you know what that
participant's intentions are you know
yes you can go into like sibo open close
you be like okay well he was doing this
he was rolling that right um but really
there's just no true way to know what
his intentions are but what we do know
is the effect that he had on the system
and that's something that we can rely on
and we can actually trade um um it's
both you know we know that he had
impacted the system in such a way that
you know if he's long some puts he's
really just making it less liquid to
trade in that area because if you're
lifting the Vols in some area that means
there's less liquidity there you think
of it as establishing like a low volume
node uh but with an active position like
that is kind of the effect of going
along those puts whether he was like
betting on downside or not
yeah and so you know we don't know what
he is right and but we do know the
effect and that also has the secondary
effect of like execution is so much
simpler if you're not trying to reason
as to why someone is doing something
like it kind of doesn't matter like if
you're like okay someone's going long
and you could be like okay but like why
would you go long here like spot price
has already been going up for so much
like why would you do that like well it
doesn't matter like he's [__] going
along just just follow
him you know you know what j i I do kind
of sympathize with many people in in in
the community because um I mean if you
go to latest in gets profile and what
would happen is like you know that level
at the moment 5,
a87 that's on on the downside like the
maximum
Yeah so basically I mean I've been using
I've been using get B for a couple of
years now so basically that's telling me
the that's a magnet and and the price
because when you see the the the let's
say like the kind of normal distribution
that you have there you know you see
there is more let's put it negative
gamma there than positive and you might
think Jesus Christ there a lot of that's
a lot of negative gamma so the price is
a magnet and the price might might go
there because the market maker might
need to HED to explose by selling
Futures right so when you when you when
you see a a big position like the one we
saw on Monday I tell you I was long I
was long I was long the Futures and I as
soon as I saw that position I was like
holy crap and I cut my long and you know
what the price never went there yeah so
and many guys many guys in the chat they
were also like kind of what this is
going to go down no we're long we
cutting the Longs so it's it's you know
it's when when you when you look at it
into what you just mentioned that that
guy is lifting the volatility surface
and it's making the option more
expensive so less likely the spot to go
there it goes against up you know at
least yeah it's very
counterintuitive yeah I I think that
because you know every like
it's it's
just a lot of talk about the options
Market um that like is very misleading
you know I mean that's kind of because
the option Market is so and you know to
be clear we're talking about like SPX
like index options right primarily like
it is not it's not a speculative
instrument like that's just not what its
purpose is you know
so people are very very used to thinking
in terms of
um uh you know I mean a spy is kind of
reflective of this where it's like okay
you come to the options Market to make a
a leveraged directional bets right and
that's kind of what fuels the thinking
of okay well someone's going along these
puts because like they're betting on on
downside um but like in in
SPX partly you know there's there's
multiple factors in this right so like
the the rise of short V you know people
selling volatility makes it very hard to
um profit off of being long V or long
gamma um it's just very difficult to to
monetize stuff especially if you're um
if you're trying to move size like that
person was or that participant was on
Monday um you know okay maybe if you
were making a speculative bet like that
they would have required like SPX to
drop significantly because just the very
Act of like taking profit on those puts
is going to shove not by itself but
people you know because there's the
feedback effect you know when you're
trying to take profit or or close
positions like that um that can make it
very difficult to to monetize it
properly um so more often than not again
with SPX it's it's for hedging right now
that doesn't mean that we can't trade
offit
speculatively um but it does require
slightly different thinking and in fact
like because it has that purpose um we
can still be very clear on like how
exactly we we're classifying flow um it
just requires a little bit of a
different reading of how to how to
utilize that
um my in my previous conversation with
John we we kind of agree and and I think
I put it in the chat in Twitter
basically to to go directional you have
to look the Spy not the you know and
that's what I do I go directional
looking spy and uh SPX I just use it for
levels to get out
basically you know to dat profits and
because those levels like today uh what
was
5922 that that was the maximum of the
recent rally on espx so basically when
there and
yeah yeah but at that time if if you go
back in time like couple of hours ago
that was the maximum kind of I think
call was right there uhuh and and but
but to go to that directional trade I I
was looking spy and and and yeah so so